bởi tiếp xúc, cứ chỉ cần thơ và nèi một số vấn đề và sình sau hương và tháng trên khai mùi hình chính quyền địa phương hay cấp,
lời bật là việc tiêu hương giãn về chì đầu cho cảm ổ trên chất chừng được số,
an toàn thuộc tìm mạng, bất tập trong phân cấp có lý trong tâm và nóa thi thao và trên thang,
quá tải trên thực tạc tức giả, còn trong chiáo trong quy định vì tắt thử đất,
chính xác khú trở cho xảan toàn khu trên đủ và chấm phí dưới tất chình một tức uc giả,
sẽ đoạn hàng in không trong hàng mi sau, hàng in không trong bà buổi.
Sẽ đắt kinh nghi, thu tưởng phạm y chính cho biết, phần lần các lỗi dùng cử chi nào đang được chính phủ,
các bộ ngành tích cửc xem xác và sĩ trong đó có việc hản thiện hướng giảm về phân cấp,
ui quyền đều chình chính xác đài và đánh yên thên dưới các hình chính một tiêu,
thu tưởng nghiên mạng chính phủ sẽ tiếp thù, xe đổi, bộ dùng theo thầm quyền,
đồng thời chính cuối hội và cấp bảo thầm quyền xâm chát những vấn đề và thầm quyền.
Thủ tưởng khẩn định môi chính quyền hải cấp là bước cả các lớn, cần tiếp tục khoảng thiệp để vận hành giữa qua,
thực chát, ông định y yết các địa phương truy động tháo gỡ khó khăn không trưởng giảm, không nghe chính giảm,
đồng thời nân tóc năng lực cám bộ, tình gọi bộ mấy chuyển mạnh tích tư dưới hành chính xanh tự dưới phục bộ.
Phải giám nghĩ giám làm không sự sai không sự chính giảm tất cả vì rất viên nước thử tự nhiên mạnh.
Đồng thời yêu cầu cần thơ phát vi tìm năng lựa thế, quyết tâm tăng trưởng hai cột số trong năm 2020.
Hoàn thành một trong bột tiêu nghiệp kỳ hành hành hành hành mốt hành hành hành hành hành m以 làm,
có phần dưới dựng vụ đồng bằng xong của lòng phát triển nhang và bị vấn.
Thủ tưởng nhấn mạnh, cần thơ có nhiều lựa thế là chúng tâm vùng thì về tiến phong, gần bộ o đi đầu, không để chẳng trạp,
thuộc em các tình cho vùng.
Cổng trong sáng mấy chi thông dười, thủ tưởng phạm miệnh chính đã đến thăm,
đồng viên và các nhân dân ở cu nhà ưu sã hội năng lòng hai thục hô đô thị mởi năng tình thơ phường
kìm chá từ gình hạt động của chúng tâm phục của hành chính công phần hương phủ.